and as
and just a weird feeling to have it
being
caretaker I wouldn't say it's a weird
fan it's a great feeling being not you
know in the position that we're in so as
a quarterback just try to put guys in
position to be successful getting the
ball but make plays in space and you
know let them take care of the rest one
of these games you are not discussed
to the running game
I assume you're ok with this alright
being undefeated yeah
Jimmy Garoppolo the 49ers quarterback
who really hasn't been tested yet this
year because they are undefeated and
most of the games have come easily Chris
we haven't seen Jimmy Garoppolo be
required to make a big play in a big
spot to win a big game that's gonna
happen at some point yep
whether it's down the stretch whether
it's in the postseason it's not going to
be this high-powered offense that never
puts any pressure on Jimmy Garoppolo to
make that key play to win a game to turn
a game around to keep a game from
falling out of control for the 49ers
and you know what hey maybe he never
will maybe the defense is so good and
the running game is so good he never
will but I think that at some point it's
inevitable he's gonna have to step up
and do something yeah I would think so
as well now yeah a lot of teams and the
way Kyle Shanahan organized his game
plans and his creativity with everything
he does and schematics on the offensive
side of the ball I mean yes to this
point they've just diced defenses up for
the most part on a week-to-week basis
and they haven't had to depend on Jimmy
Garoppolo I mean that's a great thing it
just shows you how how dominant their
team has been but yeah I would think
somewhere down the stretch whether it's
the Baltimore Ravens or the Saints or
maybe the Seahawks you know Kyle won't
be able to out scheme them you know on
every play and the run games not gonna
be able to get some of those defenses
maybe the way they have early on in the
year and that's the last question mark
we really have about the San Francisco
49ers - what you're saying when when
things aren't good can Jimmy Garoppolo
say hey guys I got you today jump on my
back I'll carry us through the fourth
quarter and win us a big football game
yeah and you'd almost like to have some
of those experiences during the regular
season so when the post season rolls
around you will have already been there
and done that and proven you can't
unless he has those experiences in the
regular season and they don't go well
right you don't want to have that test
once or twice and fail it and then that
begins to become the narrative the next
thing you know you're Kirk Cousins
that's really the question that the
49ers still have because look we
came into the year thinking this is
make-or-break for Jimmy Garoppolo there
really has been nothing that he's done
so far this year that allows us to come
to the conclusion as to whether or not
he's made it or whether or not he's
broken in San Francisco they could still
get rid of him after the year yeah I
mean you're right you know there's
nothing defining there but they're
winning and that's all that matters
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports